[Applaudissements]
chez tout le monde l'a nadège oui non
mais moi j'ai tourné avec un acteur dont
je tairai le nom qui montre son sexe
tout le temps quoi c'est que c'est une
vraie maladie non je vais pas dire c'est
vrai la région ça s'appelle le exemple
je vais pas dire non mais moi vous savez
qu'on fait l'émission l'a donc oui alors
non mais c'est vrai la maladie en fait
avoir à les payer et ce métier non mais
aussi les pays et d'acteurs saisie du
mois mais constante et pourrait voir son
sexe papa c'est un film érotique
sinon c'est normal un au milieu de la
loge comme ça il s'en faut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des nouvelles de votre quête sur un
travail est arrivé pas le faire avec le
doigt et que c'est beaucoup plus
pratique de plus en plus de gens le font
et j'ai eu otis ils ont de plus en plus
de problèmes avec ça
portage dans cet avis sur sade et des
raisons particulières de haïti vous avez
fait merci jean luc rader
on va passer au tour de magie du jour là
sa part complètement quatre matins on
l'a vu dans ce rôle
le